a fairly jaw-dropping story actually in
the times this morning finding that debt
collectors working for British gas have
been obtaining Court warrants to
forcibly enter the homes of sometimes
vulnerable customers and install
prepayment meters now the issue of
prepayment meters has been in the news
for some time after it emerged towards
the end of last year that a number of
energy companies were using these kind
of practices to put sometimes very poor
struggling customers onto prepayment
meters and clearly what happens is if
they are suddenly unable to put money in
their meter well then their energy
supplies are cut off and so for that
reason the Energy Secretary Grant shouts
wrote to energy companies in January
urging them to stop the practice but
what's happened is the times has gone
undercover with a company called arvato
Financial Solutions which is a debt
collection agency used by British gas
and it's fine some really quite alarming
practices including for example a bone
us culture in which there were bonuses
given to staff for installing these
prepayment meters which therefore caused
them to perhaps disregard the
vulnerabilities of some of their
customers people with disabilities
people with young children for example
and actually it's possible that some of
the practices are in breach of the
regulator off gems licensing conditions
the off-chem has told the times in a
statement that the concert there are
story is alarming and that off gem are
urgently investigating and the owner of
British gas centrica has said in a
rather lengthy statement that protecting
vulnerable customers is an absolute
priority and we have clear processes and
policies to ensure we manage customer
debt carefully and safely more broadly
they said there are clearly significant
challenges around affordability and
unfortunately we don't see that changing
anytime soon we need to strike a balance
between managing in spiraling bad debt
and being aware that there are those who
refuse to pay and those who cannot pay
but I also thought it was notable okay
that um British gas said in a statement
to the times that this is not who we are
this is not how we do business except
the problem is it rather seems that
that's exactly how they were doing
business until such time as a newspaper
uncovered the practices